I feel like someone like Andrew Tate
could have found that 20 year old virgin
it's not hard especially he has because
he has a lot of power he's married he is
married yeah and actually I'm going to
correct you on that he doesn't say go
out there and womanize and stuff he says
if you find a good woman hold on to her
okay you know if you find a good woman
keep her and I he does also say that
like endlessly chasing hoes is a waste
of time because hoes are hoes there's no
value you know you're gonna grow old and
you're going to be some old man in the
club like chasing hoes but he
contradicted himself in the end don't
you think no he's not because he has a
wife and children
he has the very thing you say he is
anti-again